(Video: narrador: Un hecho visto desde un punto
da una impresion.
Visto desde otro punto, da una impresión muy diferente.
Solamente cuando tienes la imagen completa puedes entender todo
lo que está ocurriendo.)
Sasa Vicinic: Es un gran video, ¿cierto?
Descubrí que en 29 segundos, dice más sobre
el poder y la importancia de los medios independientes
que lo que yo puedo decir en una hora.
Asi que pensé que sería bueno empezar con esto.
Y también con algunas estadísticas.
Según ciertos investigadores, el 83% de la población del planeta
vive en sociedades sin prensa independiente.
Piense en eso: el 83% de la población de todo el planeta
no sabe realmente lo que ocurre en sus países.
La información que reciben está filtrada por alguien
que la distorsiona o la tergiversa,
alguien que hace algo con la información.
Así, esta gente no puede entender su realidad.
Esto es para entender la gravedad del problema.
Aquellos que tienen la suerte de vivir en esas sociedades
que representan el 17%, deberían disfrutarlo mientras dure.
Imaginense la mañana del domingo leyendo el diaro con un cappuccino.
Disfrútenlo mientras dure.
Porque, según escuchamos ayer, los países pueden perder estrellas de sus banderas.
pero también la libertad de prensa,
tema que los americanos conocen muy bien.
Pero ese es otro tema.
Así que vuelvo a mi historia.
Mi historia, la que quiero compartir, comienza en 1991.
En esa época yo dirigía B92, el único medio independiente
y electrónico del país.
Y supongo que compartíamos la rutina de ser el único
medio independiente del país, funcionando en un ambiente hostil,
en el que el gobierno realmente internta hacer de tu vida una miseria.
Y hay muchas maneras de lograrlo.
Si, era lo de siempre:
algunas amenazas, algunos consejos amistosos,
algunas políticas económicas, algo de control de textos.
Y siempre habia alguien que nunca se iba de tu oficina.
Pero lo que hicieron, que es muy poderoso,
y es lo que el gobierno hacía en los 90
cuando no le gustaban los medios independientes,
era amenazar a tus anunciantes.
Una vez hecho esto, las fuerzas del mercado están
destruídas y los anunciantes no quieren aparecerse --
no importa todo lo que comprendan --
no quieren aparecer ni anunciar.
y así tenes problemas para llegar a fin de mes.
En ese tiempo, a inicios de los 90, teníamos ese problema
que era sobrevivir,
pero lo que fue muy doloroso para mi fue
en los comienzos de los 90, cuando Yugoslavia se dividía,
Estabamos sentados viendo un país derrumbarse,
derrumbarse en cámara lenta,
y teníamos todo eso en video.
Teníamos la capacidad de comprender lo que ocurría.
Realmente estábamos grabando la historia.
El problema fue que una semana después tuvimos que regrabarla
porque no podíamos pagar más cintas
para guardar los archivos de esa historia.
Por eso, si les doy esa imágen, no quisiera detenerme mucho en eso.
En ese contexto, un hombre se acerca a mi oficina.
Todavia era 1991.
Él dirigía una organización de sistemas de comunicación.
que aún esta en actividad, al igual que el hombre.
¿Y qué sabía yo en esa época de sistemas de comunicación?
Pensaba que eran organizaciones,
que nos ayudaban.
Por eso preparé dos planes estratégicos para esa reunión.
Uno grande y otro chico.
El chico se trataba de que él
nos ayude a conseguir esas cintas,
para que pudiéramos guardar ese archivo por 50 años.
El plan grande era pedirle un millón de dólares.
Porque pensaba, y aún lo hago,
que esas empresas serias e independientes son un gran negocio.
Y pensaba que B92 sobreviviría para ser una gran empresa
una vez que Milosevic se fuera, lo que resultó ser cierto.
Probablemente sea ahora la empresa más grande
o una de las más grandes del país.
En ese tiempo pensé que lo que más necesitábamos
era un millón de dólares para sobrevivir.
Para acortar la historia, el hombre viene a mi oficina,
con un flamante traje y corbata.
Le doy lo que considero una brillante explicación
de la situación política y le explico lo difícil
que será la guerra.
En realidad yo subestimaba las atrocidades, debo admitirlo.
En fin, después de esta gran explicación,
la única pregunta que tenía para mi -y no es un chiste- fue:
¿Tuvimos que pagar regalías después de pasar música
de Michael Jackson?
Esa fue la única pregunta que me hizo.
Se fue, y recuerdo que estaba muy enojado conmigo mismo
porque pensé que tenía que haber una institución en el mundo
que provea ayuda a las empresas de medios de comunicación.
Es tan obvio, tan evidente,
que alguien lo tendría que haber pensado.
Alguien tendría que haber empezado algo así.
Yo pensaba que yo era el tonto que no podía encontrarlo.
Bueno, no habia Google en ese tiempo;
No se podía usar Google en el 91
Ese era mi gran problema.
Ahora vamos de aquí rápidamente a 1995.
Dejé el país, tenia una reunión con George Soros,
para tratar por tercera vez de convencerlo de que
su fundación invierta en algo que
funcione como un banco para los medios.
Básicamente lo que proponía era simple.
No era caridad, eso no funciona;
No eran limosnas, 20.000 dólares no ayudan a nadie.
Lo que deberían es tratar a empresas de medios como un negocio.
Todo es un negocio.
El negocio de los medios, como cualquier otro, tiene que capitalizarse.
Y lo que necesitan es acceso a capital.
Por eso tenía los argumentos bien ensayados para la tecera reunión.
Al final de la reunión el dice:
"Mira, no va a funcionar, nunca más verás tu dinero
"Pero mi fundación va a poner 500.000 dólares para que pruebes la idea.
"Vas a ver que no funcionará.
Dijo, "Te doy una soga para que tu mismo te cuelgues.
(Risas)
Despúes de esa reunión supe dos cosas.
Primero, que no quiero ahorcarme bajo ninguna circunstancia,
Y segundo, que no sabía cómo hacer que funcione.
Era una gran idea
Pero una cosa es tener una idea
y otra hacer que funcione.
Así que no tenia ni idea de cómo hacerlo funcionar.
Tenia la idea incorrecta, pensaba que podíamos ser un banco
Los bancos, no sé si hay algun banquero presente,
me disculpo de antemano, pero son el mejor trabajo del mundo.
Encuentran a alguien que sea respetable
y tenga mucho dinero.
Le dan más dinero y depués de un tiempo él paga.
Ustedes juntan los intereses y no hacen nada más.
Por eso pensé en ese negocio
(Risas)
Y tuvimos a nuestro primer cliente. Brillante.
El primer diario independiente en Eslovaquia.
El gobierno los excluía
de todos los servicios de impresión en Bratislava.
Y aquí esta el diario
que tiene que imprimirse a 400km de la capital.
Cuyo plazo de entrega es a las 4 p.m.
Por eso no tiene sección deportiva,
ni últimas noticias y la circulación se reduce.
Es una manera muy sofisticada
de matar a un diario económicamente.
Ellos vinieron a pedirnos un préstamo.
Querian, la unica manera de sobrevivir
era teniendo una imprenta.
Y dijimos: bueno, reunámonos
y tráiganos su plan de negocio.
Comenzamos la reunión.
Tuve esas dos hojas, no como éstas, sino en formato A4
que es mucho más grande.
Con muchos números. Un montón
Pero los números, como quiera que los pongas
no tienen sentido.
Y eso es lo mejor que pudieron hacer.
Éramos su mejor opción.
Asi fue como entendimos cuál es nuestro método.
No es un banco. Realmente tenemos que
entrar a esas empresas y ganar nuestro dinero nuevamente
ayudándolos, estableciendo sistemas de administración,
otorgando todo el conocimiento, cómo manejar un negocio
por un lado -- todos ellos saben cómo crear contenido.
Vayamos a los resultados
En estos 10 años, 40 millones de dólares invertidos en financiación asequible,
la tasa de interés promedio es de 5 a 6 por ciento.
Últimamente, estamos descontrolados, cobrando a veces un 7 por ciento.
Hacemos esto en 17 países en vías de desarrollo.
Y la cifra más sorprendente.
la tasa de devolución, por la que Soros estaba tan preocupado: 97%
Recibimos a tiempo el 97 por ciento de todos los pagos estipulados.
¿Qué financiamos?
Cualquier cosa que una empresa de medios necesite.
Desde una imprenta hasta un transmisor.
Lo más importante es que lo hacemos
como préstamos, valores de renta, contratos de arrendamientos --
Lo que sea más apropiado para apoyar a cualquiera.
Pero lo más importante es ¿A quién financiamos?
En los últimos 10 años las empresas que
financiamos son las mejores empresas de medios de comunicación
del tercer mundo.
Esta es una lista de "Quién es Quién".
Y podría estar horas hablando de ellos
porque son como héroes.
Pero les daré solo uno,
o, dependiendo del tiempo, dos ejemplos
de con quién trabajamos.
Empezamos trabajando en Europa Central y del Este,
y continuamos en Rusia.
Nuestro primer préstamo en Rusia fue en Cheliábinsk.
Seguro que nunca escucharon de ese lugar
En el sur de Rusia hay un hombre llamado
Boris Nikolaivich que maneja
un diario independiente.
La ciudad estuvo cerrada hasta los 90
porque producian vidrio para aviones.
Bien, él maneja un periódico independiente allí.
Después de dos años con nosotros, se convierte en
el periódico más respetado del lugar.
El gobernador viene un día,
y lo invita a su oficina.
El va y visita al gobernador y éste le dice:
"Boris Nikolayevich, creo que está haciendo un gran trabajo
"tiene el periódico más respetado de nuestro distrito,
"y le quiero ofrecer un trato,
"¿Podria darme su periódico por nueve meses?
"porque hay elecciones --
"las elecciones tendrán lugar en nueve meses.
"No participaré pero es importante
"saber quien será mi sucesor.
"Así que présteme su periódico por nueve meses luego se lo devolveré
"No me interesa ser un administrador de los medios.
"¿Cuánto costaría?
Boris Nikolayevich dice: "no está en venta."
El gobernador dice: "se lo cerraremos"
Boris Nikolayevich dice: "No, usted no puede hacer eso."
Seis meses después el periódico estaba cerrado.
Por fortuna tuvimos tiempo de ayudar a Boris Nikolayevich
a tomar todos los activos de esa empresa y llevarlos a otra,
para tener todas las listas de suscripción y contratar al equipo.
Y así el gobernador solo obtuvo un cascarón.
Eso es lo que pasa si usted está en el negocio de medios independientes,
y si es un banquero para medios independientes.
Suena como una historia muy buena.
En algún lugar por ahí inauguramos un centro de administracion de medios.
Comenzamos nuestro centro, suena como una historia muy buena.
Pero hay otra versión.
En la segunda version, como en el video,
si toma la cámara de arriba comienza a pensar
nuevamente sobre estos números,
40 millones de de dólares en 10 años en 17 países.
No es mucho. ¿Cierto?
Solo es una gota en el mar.
Porque cuando pensamos en la importancia de
problemas como los que hablábamos anoche --
la sesión sobre África y sus
hipotéticos 50 billones de dólares destinados a África.
Todos, no todos, la mitad de esos problemas mencionados --
la responsabilidad del gobierno, la corrupción, y cómo combatirla,
dándoles voz a los que no son escuchados, a los pobres --
es la razón de ser de los medios independientes.
Y es la causa de que se hayan inventado.
Desde ese punto de vista, lo que hicimos es sólo
una gota en un mar de necesidad que reconocemos.
La nuestra es sólo una historia
Estoy seguro de que en este lugar hay 15 magníficas historias
de organizaciones sin fines de lucro trabajando.
Aquí yace el problema,
y se los explicaré lo mejor que pueda.
Se llama recaudación de fondos.
Imaginen que un tercio de este lugar está lleno de
personas que representan distintas fundaciones.
Imaginen que dos tercios administran excelentes organizaciones,
y realizan trabajos muy importantes.
Ahora imaginen que una de cada dos personas acá
es sorda. Ahora apaguen las luces.
Así de difícil es distinguir a las personas
de este lado de la habitación
de aquellas del otro lado de la habitación.
Por eso se necesita una gran idea
para reformar y cambiar la recaudación de fondos.
En lugar de personas en la oscuridad,
tratando de buscar su par, alguien que esté dispuesto,
que tenga los mismos objetivos,
en lugar de todo eso, pensamos que
algo nuevo necesita inventarse.
Y se nos ocurrió la idea de emitir bonos,
Bonos de libertad de prensa.
Si hay inversionistas dispuestos a financiar
el déficit presupuestario de E.E.U.U
¿Por qué no podríamos encontrar inversionistas dispuestos a financiar
el déficit de la libertad de prensa?
Decidimos hacerlo este otoño; los emitiremos
por un valor de 1,000 dólares probablemente.
No quiero hacerles mucha publicidad, ese no es el punto
El punto es, si sobrevivimos para emitirlos y
encontrar inversionitas suficientes, se podría considerar un éxito.
No hay nada que detenga a la próxima organización
a emitir bonos la próxima primavera.
Y podrían ser bonos ecologistas
Y luego, dos semanas después Iqbal Quadir podría emitir
su electricidad en bonos Bangladesh.
Y antes que lo sepan, cualquier causa social
puede ser financiada de esta manera.
Ahora soñaremos a las 11:30 -- quedan 55 segundos
Pero llevemos la idea más allá.
Ustedes lo hacen, comienzan en E.E.U.U. porque
los conceptos están más relacionadas con las mentes americanas.
Pero también lo pueden llevar a Europa
o a Asia.
Pueden, una vez que tengan todos los puntos,
pueden facilitárserlo a los invserionistas.
Poner todos los bonos en un lugar
así ellos se sientan y hacen click
Una vez que tengan más de 10
tendrán que desarrollar una especie de matriz.
¿Qué ganan los inversionistas?
Beneficios económicos y sociales.
Y eso nos da la idea de una especie de agencia de clasificación,
del tipo Morningstar.
Que diga: el impacto social aqui es espectacular, cinco estrellas.
Económicamente nos dan uno por ciento, sólo una estrella.
Ahora llevémoslo al último paso.
Una vez que tengamos todo esto,
no hay razón por la cual no puedan tener
un lugar de mercado para todo eso,
donde no puedan liquidar todos esos bonos en forma rápida.
De esa manera se organizan las financiaciones.
así no hay habitaciones oscuras, ni gente ciega
dando vueltas para encontrarse unos con otros.
Gracias.